some tempted not to do this video here
today because I want to open up to show
you some stuff I've never shown to you
before and there's a message behind why
I'm doing this because I think sometime
when people win you forget where you
were at one point you start believing
all the hype you get cocky and boom
that's me get caught you know when I was
21 years old I was making good money I
was the speaker on the these yachts and
people would come to hear me speak in
Newport Beach and girls and all these
girlfriends and partying in Vegas and
all the stuff in a bowl I lost
everything one month I was depressed I
was living in my apartment I don't want
to talk to anybody
self-esteem you know insecure I'll just
embarrass everybody saw me at the top
and had a massive fall and you know I
told myself I get a second chance and
I'm not gonna do the same way I did the
first time run because I'm gonna change
and so I'm gonna be very careful of not
getting cocky I'll be confident but not
cocky not arrogant assertive is fine and
I'll be about the people about everybody
else I'm working with because that's
what really matters and then eventually
your own dreams and goals will become a
reality so let me show you some of this
stuff so you know what this stuff is to
me I like to document my life in a
different way some people do it with
video Instagram Facebook snapped a lot
of things this right here has a lot of
meaning to me this is the game donkey
pump me tell you why this is a lot of
meaning to me back in the days when I
was living in Iran I've done a street
called courgette kale Bonneville jet and
on the corner of Calvin or jet there was
a store that sold video games and they
had this one I would always go to my dad
and say dad I want to buy that game for
me buy it for me says I'm not buying it
why not you gotta go talk to her oh no
I'm not talking to the owner you're
paying for it if you don't talk mom not
buying it for you I wouldn't talk to the
guy for two months finally I did he
bought it for me this isn't the original
one but my sister bought one and said
them to me two years ago obviously
haven't played it but every time I look
at it I think about that moment this is
a pipe my uncle was a big pipe guy he
just died three months ago but this pipe
tells me a lot about the memories I had
with them this is a wallet this is the
first expensive wallet I bought it's
Hugo Boss wallet 80 bucks I mean 80
bucks is nothing you can buy thousand
all the wallet nowadays but this was a
big deal because to me it was like wow
rather than buying these $5 Wallis now
you bought it $80 Wadena much story have
with this wallet this was given to me
the
month I left Germany by my classmate
that was 12 years old look at the date
November let me see if I move my finger
November 1990
I came to America November 28th 1990 you
know what's in there
everybody's stories pictures their ideas
their hobbies my friendship with them I
look at this it takes me to a really
nice place in my life this book this is
the story of Shaw when I was born in
Iran he was still the king of Iran I was
born October of 78 he was in exile three
months later but when I was born he was
a shot I remember anything about this
guy because I was newborn baby but I
probably read this book on her how many
times I've read this book he told this
book he wrote this book before he died
and so what I did after this book I went
about every single time magazine he was
ever on kind we show you some of these
magazines you know Iran and turmoil date
September 18 1978 was born four weeks
after that Iran and Anarchy Exodus
February 26 1979 I was four months old
okay again Iran it to Ramona I buy every
one of these things when I find him
Time magazine December 18 1978 the
toughest Shahs toughest test was two
months old the center of store December
10th 1979 about a yeren two months old
okay the Emperor's oil 1974 this is when
Iran was strong in the Middle East there
was no war everything was that peace
this right here probably thousands cars
with these in LA god Bless America when
Morgan Stanley wouldn't give up my
license I bought these at two dollars
and sold it for 10 bucks just pay my
bills when my license was being
transferred for like three four months
uh this is the first time I got a hold
of twenty Robin said I would listen to
this this is old school if you've seen
this great but this is like video
cassettes I'd listen to it over and over
again this was given to me in July on
July 18 2009 by a bunch of people I work
with and back in a days at a sales
organization we call us of the story
builders there's stories here from all
these
people in my life that they wrote every
once in a while I sit there and I just
read them and I just read them many of
them are no longer in my life but every
one of them has a place in my heart
because there's a story to it right this
the first time a major publication did a
story on me Denver Post
home-buying try some extreme logic
that's me
with that orange French Connection
sweater I have on okay um let me show
you some other stuff just the first
website I ever made the story builders
you know why this is important my best
friend was no longer with us
our men are Italian wrote a story if you
know the story you know exactly what
it's about this was my first workout
shirt I bought when I was 14 years old
24-hour Fitness see the one I have on
this was made by a Latina but this is
the original one check this one out
okay okay I ripped it is the armpits
okay
see it ripped ripped didn't have a lot
of money man we came from very simple
background everything is ripped on this
the back is even ripped and I would wear
it ripped to work yet people say Pat why
are you doing this so look this is legit
stuff I'm working out this is the book I
bought for my wife a day after we went
on our first date a hundred or more
questions to us before you get engaged
this is the original one with my
original answers embarrassing answers
and I kept it why maybe one day my kids
are gonna want to read this and realize
how crazy their Dennis it's my last
license from California why California's
got a place in my heart this Bible was
given to me let me tell you what this is
so important some of you guys didn't
know and heard me tell the story before
this is that Bible I was an atheist 25
years of my life when I was in the Army
they give us the opportunity to go for a
camp by a lake and we had to do Bible
study every night for one hour us look
so annoying the smell would speak you
would speak monotone or just a bad kid
temper all that other stuff at the end
it comes and gives and me this Bible he
says this Bible was given to me by mom
and dad
on December 25th 1974 son I think you
need this more than I do
prayed every single day three times a
day to God I didn't believe licks
literally this shirt here okay when I
was broke buddies in downtown LA for two
bucks a pop Osama your mama during 9/11
I'd sell these for 15 bucks a pop you
know my kept all this stuff everyone
like there's so many other things in
front me I'm not gonna go through all of
them beyond this for like 30 minutes I
will never forget where I came from
and every single time you have massive
victory like you're coming up hardcore
and you're making millions you have to
realise just like everything was given
to you the moment you get cocky is when
you get caught the moment you're no
longer prepared is when you get caught
the moment you think this is gonna
continue you're untouchable that's when
somebody takes it away from you and so
if you're watching this and you're on
the rise like you have nothing
you're like Pat I wish I had a you know
$5,000 in a bank account let alone you
know millions look whatever you're doing
document by keeping everything I've kept
every single one of my credit scores
checked every single thing because when
are you gonna tell that story to your
kids to your family and somebody else
you gonna inspire but if you're winning
and you're watching this and you're
catching yourself your language sounds a
bit cocky go back and sit down and go
through some of your old stuff and
remember they used to suck at one point
you just have nothing at one point used
to be depress on one point you stab
insecurities at one point you lost a
girl you lost your savings you lost a
job you got fired don't get too cocky be
grateful be confident be assertive keep
working on yourself out work out improve
out strategize outlast and success will
continue but if you don't either go to
somebody else who appreciate success and
is gonna show up on a daily basis it's a
simple message to difference to two
different types of people those on the
rise and those are all the way at the
top looking down feeling it
finit and they don't realize there's
another mountain to go to but if you
want to go on that other mountain you're
gonna get up there acting the way you
are right now you got to recreate
yourself to be able to get to the next
level and if you do you get to the next
level you don't you're gonna stay where
you're at you drop cuz you had to move
up or you go down you never stay in the
same place it's my message to week to
you by the way let's have a killer Week
this week
okay love you buh-bye